esta división de polinomios ha sido un
poco más divertido de lo que esperábamos
así que sigamos digamos que una vez más
alguien se acerca a ti en la calle y te
pregunta cuál es el resultado de equis
cuadrada + 1 / x2 pausa el vídeo e
intenta encontrar la respuesta pero te
voy a dar una advertencia este ejercicio
es un poco más complicado de lo que
esperas bien existen dos formas de
resolverlo ya sea que intentemos de
expresar el numerador de tal manera que
involucre a x + 2 de una forma o podemos
intentar hacer una división algebraica
larga primero intentemos de la primera
forma x cuadrada más 1 no es obvio que
se pueda actualizar pero habrá forma de
escribir algo que tenga x + 2 como
factor
y es muy interesante que no tenemos
términos de primer grado y lo más
interesante que se me puede ocurrir es
desarrollar una diferencia de 4 a 2
usando a x + 2 sabemos que x + 2 x x
menos 2
es lo mismo que x cuadrada menos 4 qué
tal si escribimos x cuadrada menos 4 por
aquí y después tenemos que agregar 5
para obtener más 1 es decir que te
parece si escribimos x cuadrada menos 4
+ 5 ya que esta expresión y la de arriba
son completamente equivalentes pero
porque hice esto bueno porque ahora
puedo escribir x cuadrada menos 4 como x
2 x x menos 2 y entonces puede
reescribir toda esta expresión entera
como x + 2 x x menos 2 todo esto entre x
+ 2 + 5 entre x + 2
ahora mientras x no sea igual a menos 2
podemos dividir el numerador y el
denominador por x2 y nos quedaremos con
x menos 2 + 5 / x + 2 y necesito poner
ni restricción para decir que esta
expresión es la misma que la expresión
que tenemos arriba tenemos que escribir
que x no puede ser igual a menos 2 y ya
está podemos decir oye x cuadrada + 1 /
x + 2 es igual a x menos 2 y después
tenemos como residuo a 5 este es mi
residuo
ahora vamos a intentar resolver lo mismo
usando una división algebraica larga y
verás que esta forma de resolverlo es un
poco más directa entonces x + 2 va a
dividir a x cuadrada + 1 y tenemos que
tener cuidado con los distintos lugares
para los diferentes grados x cuadrada
más uno no tiene términos de primer
grado pero escribiré el 1 hasta acá para
respetar los términos de primer grado
entonces tengo la columna de los
términos de segundo grado después un
espacio porque no tenemos términos de
primer grado y hasta el final el 1 que
es el término constante o el término de
grado 0 y hagamos lo mismo cuántas veces
cabe x en x cuadrada trabajamos con los
términos de grado mayor x cabe en x
cuadrada x veces como x es de primer
grado lo escribiré arriba de la columna
de los términos de primer grado y me
queda
quizás por 2 2 x x x x es x cuadrada y
ahora queremos restar a que se da igual
esto bueno observa que las x cuadradas
se cancelan y ahora tengo que estar
menos 2 x de bueno puedes verlo como 0 x
+ 1 entonces nos quedamos con menos 2x y
bajamos el 1
x cabe en menos 2 x menos 2 veces así
que lo escribiré en mi columna de
términos constantes y dice menos 2 x 2
es menos 4 y menos 2 por x es menos 2x
tenemos que tener mucho cuidado aquí
porque queremos restar el menos 2 x
menos 4 de menos 2 x 1 podemos pensarlo
de esta manera o simplemente distribuir
el signo negativo y cambiarles de signo
me quedara + 2 x 4 y ahora el menos 2 x
+ 2 x se cancelan y más uno más 4 es
igual a más 5 como no hay una manera
obvia de dividir al 5 entre x + 2
entonces decimos que el 5 es nuestro
residuo exactamente como teníamos acá
abajo cuando hacemos la división
algebraica larga obtenemos x menos 2 lo
mismo que acá abajo con un residuo de